coming up in strasburg next week in the
last plenary session before the summer
break the big issues of the day he tip a
new effort to forge political unity
Greece a full debate with commission and
council leaders financing solutions to
the migration crisis the circular
economy copyright law and fighting tax
evasion in the developing world what is
the circular economy it's one of
Europe's current buzz themes and it's
basically the opposite of the linear
economic model that everybody uses today
that's so wasteful the make use and
dispose model going circular minimizes
waste and extract maximum value from the
resources we use sounds kind of utopian
in today's consumer-led world well Emmy
PS don't think so on Monday they'll be
debating next steps towards efficient
use of resources a country of 11 million
rarely off people's lips with
intractable debt problems grease em eps
will debate latest developments in this
fast-moving story with two leaders at
the heart of the talks jean-claude
Juncker President of the European
Commission and Donald Tusk President of
the European Council following June's
agreement on managing Europe's migration
crisis mep s are putting their money
where their mouths are preparing to
release 75.8 million euros to Europe's
Border Agency Frontex for more aerial
and maritime surveillance and to help
member states hardest hit like diesel
Italy around 2,000 people have perished
in the Mediterranean this year also
coming up next week debates on the end
of latvia's presidency of the EU and the
start of luxembourg's one on monday
there'll be a debate on door to door
single ticketing by NE transport means
with a vote the next day the same day
there will be a commemoration of the
massacre of Sri burnet Samara and mostly
men and boys were slaughtered in the
Bosnian war on Wednesday its tax evasion
in developing countries many of which
receive EU development aid and the same
day a debate on the upgrade of copyright
legislation any PS will try to remove
obstacles in the trend
Atlantic trade and investment
partnership between the EU and the u.s.
it's been mired in controversy over the
investor state dispute settlement
mechanism which according to opponents
would allow powerful corporations to sue
governments if they felt their interests
where unfairly threatened a debate and a
vote were pulled from the June plenary
but have been reinstated on Tuesday and
Wednesday and that's it enjoy the week